today on stick to football we're gonna
go back over a couple big games from the
weekend that we missed kicked off after
our Stanford tell you we're going to
look at some of the things happening
around the NFL they're gonna affect the
NFL Draft as well as the playoffs and we
are going to fix the Atlanta Falcons
which I tweeted out Tuesday morning this
is a tall job for a team that has some
cap problems some aging players at key
positions but Connor we have a fun show
today with also a lot of draft on draft
questions yeah we really do you guys
have been great about sending those
questions in so we really appreciate
that we're gonna get through a ton of
those today probably two full segments
on it and of course Matt we've gotten a
lot of questions about the Atlanta
Falcons and we've called this one of the
most desirable potential jobs on the NFL
market this year so this one it'll be a
lot of fun to fix it see how we want to
tailor the roster not really a lot of
free agency boot moves but a lot of mock
draft kind of moves but before we get
into any of that one more reminder that
we will be at the SEC championship game
partnered with Johnsonville our guests
will be Sean Alexander that's on
December 7th right outside mercedes-benz
stadium before the game there's gonna be
a cook-off competition professional
cornhole players over there it's gonna
be a lot of fun it's gonna be great so
if you were unable to make any of the
tailgate tour stops as we officially
wrapped up our regular season schedule
we got one more bonus one over there
down in Atlanta yes that's gonna be a
fun one gonna be a good day
action-packed day we are gonna record
the podcast Sean Alexander will be
hanging out with this so a lot going on
if you're going to the SEC championship
game come find us like Conor said right
in front of mercedes-benz so easy easy
to find all right let's jump in around
the league a little bit Conor one thing
we missed on Saturday because we
recorded early was the Arizona State
game against Oregon a huge win for
Arizona State probably the biggest we've
seen our guy Herm Edwards win there
mylord will be all wrong about that one
but herm gets the job done against
Justin Herbert and I think the key here
we could talk about Brandon IU if we
could talk about everything we love from
Arizona State but it's really the
struggles of Justin Herbert we're what
shocked me most and this is something
that I feel like we are a benefit
because we talk about the draft
year-round so we've been talking about
this for a couple months but it seems
like this was put on a national stage
Saturday
Justin Herbert
for all the traits and the arm strength
and he's big and he's mobile
there are times he just misses with
passes and it's why I've told you guys
before I get a Blaine Gabbert vibe from
Justin Herbert very often because of the
missus now can that be fixed
I think that remains to be seen
situations gonna dictate a lot story
says NFL future ghosts because there are
really beautiful traits there but like
Josh Allen like drew Locke like some of
these guys we've seen the last few
classes I think the success of Justin
Herbert will be dictated by where he
goes the NFL and if he's given time to
develop because he is not what I would
consider a plug-and-play quarterback
prospect right now I'm with you all the
way I mean we've had concerns from the
get-go with this one I think when you
look at Justin Herbert here the
composure has been a big question mark
this was a game that organ had to have I
mean Oregon had a shot here Matt to be
in the college football playoff yeah and
they had a good shot to be in the
college football playoff now you play at
Arizona State
Arizona State has played up to their
level of competition the entire year but
that's not an excuse I mean the two
interceptions even getting away from the
turnovers there were times where he was
just sailing the football high out of
bounds and I think when it comes down to
it for a Herbert does he have all the
physical talent of course he does
there's no question about that with
Justin Herbert he has all the tools to
develop but when you look at the natural
things like being calm and collected
like hitting those big-time throws like
living up to what you're expected to do
in the moment it's just not there
and Justin Herbert's gonna be a
first-round pick some team is going to
risk their jobs on that and I think
that's a risky risky play I wouldn't do
it and I just think when you look at
this quarterback class I know there's
gonna be you know some teams and flux
because Joe burrow is gonna go very
early I think to us still goes really
early even with the injury question yeah
but after that there's no sure thing but
if there's anything we've learned this
year Justin Herbert certainly falls into
that category of no sure thing yeah and
you know my my issues with him so people
aren't thinking that we're just you know
picking and choosing here he misses a
lot of easy throws
this is largely a one read offense I
mean he's making one read and chucking
the ball or than trying to move doesn't
set his feet in the pocket he doesn't
scan the field at all like I don't ever
see him get to second third fourth
progression watching Joe Burrell played
us one of my favorite things is you see
his head move he's checking his
progressions you don't see that with
Justin Herbert and yes they're beautiful
throws that he'll make two weeks ago
against Arizona he may were the best
nurse I've ever seen him make dropping
it over the top perfectly placed
excellent timing but he just misses way
too many easy throws from my liking and
so yeah we're gonna talk a lot about in
the next five months the disparity of
where we rank Justin Herbert versus
where we predict he will be drafted
because they are not gonna line up I can
already guarantee you that one now
speaking of quarterbacks because this is
I mean it's taking over the NFL the play
of young quarterbacks your guys Sammy
Meade Arnold has been so good the last
several weeks I actually tweeted this on
Sunday it's good to see Good Sam darn
'old again the guy that I mean he was my
number one quarterback coming out he was
mellows number one quarterback coming
out and there were times this year where
I was afraid to say that because he you
know had like the game wants the
Patriots where is the Patriots that'll
happen the game against the Jags you
know rip those were bad games but
looking what he did against the Cowboys
early in the year it's like okay we saw
like some potential then you know the
bounce back four touchdowns against the
Redskins two against the Raiders in a
blowout win he's playing that same brand
of consistent but attacking football
that made me love him at USC and when
the offensive line protects him he can
do beautiful things so I think that's
where when we talk about fixing the Jets
right now they would pick 10th they got
to go all in on this offensive line to
help Sam d'Arnaud yeah they really do
and it's no coincidence that I believe
they're four and one or they I know they
have a winning record when Calvin
Beecham plays at left tackle for them so
when they have their starting left
tackle and this new unit on the interior
you look at rot the transition from Ryan
Khalil to Jonathan Harrison there's been
a big difference there just in November
Darnell it's been really really
phenomenal I mean ten total touchdowns
just two turnovers he's completing over
66% of his passes and he's averaging 275
yards passing per game
those are franchise quarterback numbers
and that's what a lot of people believe
Sam's Arnold can be and he's 22 years
old Matt so we're used to seeing this
rollercoaster for quarterbacks that age
we've seen it really across the league
for quite some time and I think if you
were a fan of Sam Donald's or a fan of
the Jets you have to be very happy for
the steps he's taken and you also have
to wonder yeah you had the great game
against Dallas returning from mono but
that doesn't mean he was full throttle
110% ready to go I think that's
something to point out and I saw you put
it in the rundown and it is funny that
the New York Post wrote about Sam Donald
um is this celebrating with his team and
celebrating Darryl Roberts 29th birthday
and they they had this big note that it
was at bounce in New York City the Jets
and NFL players have been going to
bounce forever so it was like this big
thing it's like I think it's a good
thing that Sam's Arnold is out with
members of the defense that's what you
want to see he's out with Jamal Adams
Marcus may shermaine Johnson who has not
been very good for the Jets but the
point still stands I would rather the 22
year old quarterback after a blowout win
going out to celebrate with members of
the team than being a complete hermit
and not and you've won three straight
games I mean this they were one in seven
at the break at the halfway mark this
team was reeling you've won three
straight you're 22 years old I
celebrated landing in San Francisco
harder than that
like come on it's not a big deal I don't
I could not imagine living as a
professional athlete in New York just
the attention would be unbearable we do
have one NFL game next week's NFL
schedule is actually amazing but we have
one game that already feels like game of
the year might be a Super Bowl preview
the way both teams are playing the
Ravens and Niners play next week and
after watching these two teams play with
watching the Niners Sunday night
watching the Ravens on Monday night I
have never been more excited to watch
like last year Rams Chiefs the whole
country was like buzzing about but you
knew no one was playing defense in that
game on in this game both offenses the
Ravens offense obviously more prolific
than the 49ers but what the two defenses
are doing is
I don't know if this is just me as a
Niners homer or what but this game feels
like number one it should be flexed to
the Sunday night game over the place
Texans and number two I don't know that
there's been a game to show that I'm
more excited to just watch the X's and
O's matchup of these two teams I mean
I'm with you all the way because when
you look at the matchup on paper we are
getting coordinator matchups that are
probably future had coaches in this
league whether it's the assistant on the
offensive staff for Kyle Shanahan Mike
McDaniel
whether it's Robert Salah or their
defensive coordinator who's probably
getting a head coaching job whether it's
Greg Roman whose name is picking up a
ton of steel everybody's done in
Baltimore I mean this isn't just
Harbaugh Shanahan this is staff first
staff and elite staffs
Lamar Jackson the frontrunner for the
MVP the Ravens with all kinds of players
stepping up on the defense right now
Marcus Peters I mean holy [ __ ] what a
great great acquisition for Baltimore
and then look at the Niners what they've
done Fred Warner maybe the most
underrated front 7 player in all of
football right now Nick Bosa the entire
defensive line it's just this is gonna
be I mean this can truly truly be yet
another Super Bowl preview and I think
with Greg Roman I'm glad you mentioned
him he's going back to San Francisco
where he was the offensive coordinator
under Jim Harbaugh so there is some
famiglia already there I think that you
know he would I'm sure this game he
would like to win and I think for Greg
this is a lot of validation that this is
that offense that they ran with Colin
Kaepernick this is just a evolved
version of that what they're doing in
Baltimore so I think that if you are an
owner or a general manager that wants to
get a little outside the box right now
Greg Roman at 47 years old is a really
interesting name because of what he he
is a quarterbacks coach he's has tight
ends coach experience he has offensive
line coach experience but this is a dude
that like he knows how to coach up
offenses in quarterback so I think Greg
Roman is a really interesting name the
matchup of that offense against Roberts
allows defense is gonna be amazing and I
tweeted this out I feel like the Niners
are one of the only teams on paper that
could stop the Ravens run game without
having to overcommit in the box which is
what we've seen
everyone have to do like you have to
respect Lamar as a runner and you have
to respect Mark Ingram and Gus Edwards
in Justice Hill so you get sucked up
into loading up the box and then they
gash you up the seem like we saw last
night so I think I want to see the
Niners go man-to-man against the Ravens
and just see what happens because they
might be one of the few teams they can
do that Nick Bosa against Ronnie Stanley
it's also like that's scouting porn
watching those two all pros go at each
other is gonna be phenomenal so
hopefully both teams are at full
strength Joe Staley hopefully back for
this one because somebody's got stopped
mad jus daun right now no one's doing it
it's crazy I mean he's about to get a
lot of money in free agency
well-deserved and then when you look at
the Niners with salla I mean they're
just doing a lot of different things
this year that's great coaching the
adjustments they've made they've been a
little more willing to play man coverage
I believe Richard Sherman came out and
said that and when you look at going
back one more note on Greg Roman before
we close out this segment Matt it is
hilarious that and how hard the NFL can
be Greg Roman was fired from the Bills
two games into the 26th season by Rex
Ryan after the bills scored 31 points in
a loss and Rex's defense gave up almost
500 yards so sometimes the wrong guy is
fired and it's great to see him rebound
take a break we come back we're gonna
fix those Atlanta Falcons the Atlanta
Falcons headed into this year we really
thought this is a team they have the
quarterback they got running backs
receivers guys on defense maybe they can
make some noise in the NFC South instead
they're reeling right now projected to
pick number six overall Dan Quinn is on
the hot seat Thomas Dimitrov on the hot
seat and Connor they have a projected -
eight million dollars in salary cap
space for next year this is a team that
desperately needs our help
first I want to look at some guys who
will be free agents Austin Hooper
playing as well as any tight end not
named George Kittel right now Austin
Hooper's gonna be afraid yet Vic Beasley
had that one great year been kind of a
bust ever since Jack Crawford Adrian
Claiborne so a lot of guys on defense
there there will be four HS I think that
factors a lot into how we have to make a
plan for them but first and foremost Dan
Quinn has as a head coach seems like a
guy this team really believes in they
rallied a couple weeks ago got a couple
wins but
have a big big setback this past weekend
and so when I look at this Arthur Blank
is a patient man he's a good owner has a
ton of money invested into this team
with the new stadium are they gonna have
to find a new head coach that can turn
this around
the Falcons since halftime of the Super
Bowl against the Patriots have looked
like a completely different team then
the group that got there I think some of
that you can say Kyle Shanahan and Mike
McDaniel are gone that's been huge for
this offense that hasn't been able to
find consistency since then but Dan
Quinn's defense which is his specialty
has not looked great either
it is not man and the thing is when you
look at the Falcons roster here
you said it Matt there's not really a
lot of fat to trim these contracts have
significant guaranteed money left on
them don't get me wrong they're mostly
with good players I can't sit here and
crap on you for drafting well and
extending your talent but there's not a
lot of wiggle room where they can go fix
things in free agency they're gonna have
to draft well and I think that's why it
goes back to what do we do here at the
head coaching spot because do you think
this year is just it's a down year I
don't think so I think Dan Quinn has
simply struggled since Kyle Shanahan
left I was wrong about this team I
thought they'd be in the hunt for a
wild-card spot all along they're three
and eight the defense has been you know
basically horrendous for all things
considered they can't stop the pass they
need corners they need a pass rush but
let's really kick it off Matt assuming
they do look at the head coaching market
what direction do they go in because
this should be the number one job
available if the Dallas Cowboys job
doesn't open up yeah I would say as long
as Dallas doesn't open up then this is a
big one and I think that you know we
have been throwing out a lot of the same
names over and over again but that's
because they are the top names and I saw
I think you've said it Roberts ala Mike
McDaniel
those are big names Josh McDaniel woody
is he willing to leave New England or is
he tabbed as the guy who's gonna replace
Bill Belichick those are the the big NFL
names you know Dan Campbell and Pete
Carmichael with the New Orleans Saints
would they go in the division to a rival
like the Atlanta Falcons to be head
coaches I think they are interesting
guys Greg Roman
would be a lot of fun with this offense
but also like Matt Ryan doesn't fit what
Greg wants to do offensively so how
would that how would those two fit
together and blend together then I think
you go back to the CEO type guys Matt
rule
Matty Campbell coming from the college
game would be potential guys that I
think could be a fit here just because
what they bring to the table Chris
Rashard who's the the defensive passing
game coordinator which is a dumb title
for the Cowboys yeah if they don't shake
up the head coach he could be someone
who could be on the move I think that
would be interesting I've talked about
this before oftentimes we don't see
teams go from a defensive coach to a
defensive coach so a lot of the names
are gonna be offensive you know Kevin
Stefanski Eric be enemy I don't think we
would see a Matt Eber flues here or Dave
Tabb would be a kind of a surprise even
though there's a bit of a connection to
some of that Belichick style and Scott
Pioli who was here previously but
there's not like a clear-cut name I know
I just listed like nine there's not one
name where I'm like oh my god this this
coach will be perfect there I mean
outside of Lincoln Riley which I think
you can say any team that has some
offensive pieces Lincoln Riley would be
a really fun fit I think the question is
is this the job where Mike McDaniel gets
a look because of how successful this
franchise was when Kyle Shanahan was
there and the belief that Mike McDaniel
will take all of those great things he's
worked on with Kyle Shanahan I know it's
under him yeah but the two have really
worked great together
and that's the relationship there is
this the job that he finally gets that
look and can bring you know that
offensive powerhouse back to Atlanta I
think mike is a really interesting name
there because the the Shanahan
connection I also think and we are huge
fans of Mike McDaniel and I'm not
telling secrets out here but Mike had he
went to rehab for our for alcoholism and
I think that's something that anyone
who's gonna hire him as a head coach has
to really look into and this is one of
those things like it's known but it's
not known because how long ago that was
I actually don't know but I know that
he's been you know clean and sober ever
since and that's that's awesome like
that's what we
is war you know these guys to figure out
like okay what it what is your trigger
and how can you be better and so I think
for Mike like that's a great thing that
that he has been clean and that he's
healthy but if you're the Falcons like
you have to dig into that and I think
maybe that they're the team like you
said they can do that because of the
relationship with college been there and
and they know they know what this guy
brings to the table a little bit so I
think that's exciting because it would
be great for Matt Ryan and Julio Jones
because this is an offense that they've
they've been in before and like you said
I mean he was there for that I guess two
years under Kyle as an offensive
assistant it was before he was really
elevated to a coordinator role but
there's some familiarity there that
would make that a really exciting fit
yeah I think so too that's the one name
for me in Atlanta that I look at and go
if you want to go the route where the
Packers kind of surprised a lot of
people with Lafleur Sean McVeigh at the
time was a very big surprise for the
Rams
I think McDaniel is the guy in Atlanta
where I look at and they'd make that
higher and a lot of people would go wow
another guy that's under 40 years old he
has been an offensive assistant his
entire career you know is he ready to
lead a football team and I would sit
there and celebrate it I think you would
be a very exciting hire I the thing I
love about Mike is the head coaching
candidate is I mean you mentioned a
couple guys in Matt Lafleur and Sean
McVeigh and obviously they have a
relationship there and I think they're
similar as coaches but I think when
McDaniel he's so similar to Kyle in that
he's great at scheming you know he's not
gonna be the stand up in front of the
room rah-rah guy like Sean McVeigh but
what he does as a an X's and O's schemer
in the run game I think is unparalleled
in the NFL
Greg Romans really good don't get me
wrong and Kyle's done a great job of
evolving his dad's offense but when you
talk to folks who know these guys about
what makes this team tick it's Mike
McDaniel you know sitting in a closet
basically scheming out the run game is
what makes him so valuable and it's why
guys like Matt Breda can come in and you
know pop off you know 100 yards any week
basically so I think McDaniel would be a
blast here I think some of the
definitely the personnel matches up
really well because again we've seen
them have success with that type of
office so getting mad
Ryan back to what worked would be a
beautiful thing he said Mike's 36 years
old sir he's a young guy but I think if
you are willing to accept the this is
not gonna be like a PR move because he's
not Sean McVeigh as far as personality
goes but this might be a move that just
lets you win football games and I think
Arthur Blank can sell that now we
mentioned Conor you said it well they
have they don't have a lot of fat that
they can trim but they need to because
the salary cap is an absolute mess here
that is in large part because Matt Ryan
will count 35 million 33 million dollars
excuse me against the 2020 salary cap
Julio Jones will count 20 million Jake
Matthews 16 million and Grady Jarret
another 16 million now where things
could get interesting I think we've
heard before there was some interest in
trading Devon to Freeman you can cut
Devon to Freeman and save about five
million dollars excuse me three and a
half million dollars so I think we could
see him gone you can cut Desmond Trufant
who I love but it's 29 years old and
saved five million dollars you can
release Tyson Brailler who you drafted
to replace you drafted Kayla McGarry to
replace this guy you could say 4 million
dollars and Alex Mack who's a 34 year
old sinner still a good player but is he
worth
you could save 8 million dollars by
cutting Alex Mack so making you
restructure him but 8 million dollars
for Alex Mack this is I don't wanna say
it's poor cap management but I cut four
players and save this team 19 million
dollars in salary cap space so that's
what they have yeah you make that there
you go there's your money and half of
that goes to the draft class so when you
look at it it's like okay can the other
can you bring back
Austin Hooper for eight million dollars
a year right I don't know I don't know
[ __ ] teams get crazy on the free agent
market nowadays and there's not a lot of
good tight ends so it's gonna be
interesting and those are if they make
those cuts maybe they ride it out one
more year it's lots of Freeman and so a
lot of his dead money's gone although
listen if you could save even a little
bit of money at running back and draft
someone as his replacement
but this also goes back to who they hire
I mean once again McDaniel was an
offensive assistant in there when things
were cookin maybe that he wants to keep
Freeman if they did make that kind of
hire if they didn't yeah it's really
interesting so let's get right into it
about this draft because we went through
the coaches we went through what can be
a limited free age
see for Atlanta right here is the meat
and potatoes outside of the coaching
higher of how to rebuild this team yeah
and they have seven picks which is good
news they have two and round two thanks
to the Traven New England so let's start
off here round one pick six I am going
back to those needs because of free
agency Vic Beasley is gone the Jack
Crawford's gone Adrienne clay Birds gone
I think they need to get an edge rusher
opposite tack McKinley someone with some
power to their game I'm a little AJ
epinasty here again I actually like this
roster and I think eat whether it's Dan
Quinn or someone else they're gonna have
to find a pass rush somewhere it can't
always be blitzes it can't always be
we're gonna have to bring five or six
guys to get home and obviously Vic
Beasley has not panned out so going in a
japanesse ax I think one of the cleaner
prospects in this draft because he SICS
speed he has power he's produced in Iowa
over the last two years a japanesse a
here for me it's honestly just like a
really good value and it meets the need
of this team I'm with you I love that
pic right there when you look at sixth
overall and I think just to explain
something here Matt I'm sure you're
thinking the same as me we both think
Jeff accout is going in the top five
right or he would be the hands-down pick
yeah I think Jeff CUDA is the perfect
pick for this team I don't have them
falling to six love your pick of epinet
I'm gonna go with the front seven as
well a little bit more of a chess piece
player and that's Isaiah Simmons I think
when you look at this Falcons team
they've done a pretty good job of
getting guys that can play with speed
you know whether it was Keanu Neal
Dionne Jones this list goes on and on
but they still need more and they're
gonna turn this thing over and when you
look at Isaiah Simmons you have maybe a
tight end eraser a guy that can rush the
passer a guy that could stop the run
sideline to sideline he really can do it
all this is where you're sitting there
much like you did with epinet and you're
going we got to load up this defense
right now let's take the best player on
the board
yeah and that's right going around to
still got a load up on defense like you
said Jeff a coup had gone around one so
I'll get Jeff Gladney from TCU in round
two would pick 37 I love Jeff Gladney I
think he is right now one of the more
underrated corners in this class I've
told you in mellow this might be my
rocky ass in a guy that mid season I
really fell in love with and he said
like there's no reason he shouldn't be a
top
pick I'm getting there with Jeff Gladney
as well someone who has size physicality
and for a corner group that they've
thrown draft picks that we just haven't
seen like we haven't seen Isiah Oliver
take that next step you know they they
had a okay the name just lost me they
had a bust a couple years ago who was
like very quickly off the team Collins
from LSU Kendall Sheffield I like but I
think he'll always be a nickel so
getting a safe shut down corner here not
shut excuse me not shut down a safe
corner here is a really smart move yeah
Jeff glad needs to become a bit of a
darling for us at the top around to
we're really excited to see him down in
Mobile he could really you know solidify
himself it's one of the better corners
in this draft that you don't have to
spend a top-15 pick on I went with the
pass rusher here you went and got that
in round one with that Vanessa I go to
round two
Curtis Weaver this guy is 13 and a half
sacks now the question is will he
declare you know is he somebody that
needs to go back to school have a senior
bowl under his resume to solidify
himself as a top 40 kind of player but I
really like Weaver as a pass rush
prospect I remember asking you about him
about a month ago I said you know do I
need to go watch this guy Curtis Weaver
and you're like yeah you know what
you'll be surprised because he's pretty
good and he deserves to go in at least
the second round so for Atlanta here
they need more pass rush help at adding
Simmons and Weaver to me to the front
seven is an instant boost this defense
round to pick 63 again this one from New
England so it'll most likely be very
late in the round clutch grade by the
way great yes it was absolutely great
trade for them I love this move here
Neville Gallimore who's been under the
radar at Oklahoma all year but he next
to Grady Jarrett like you're just
causing problems for offensive lines
when you have the quickness the first
step power of these two guys lining up
side by side I'm a big Gallimore fan I
don't think we've had time yet to really
talk about him enough redshirt senior so
we probably see him at the Senior Bowl
this year 63 320 pounds so he's a little
bit of a stocky kind of bowling ball
build guy but he has power and his first
step has just been wrecking people in
the big 12 this year yeah that's
definitely a new name that we haven't
heard a lot of buzz on which is why it's
fun to do these mock drafts every week
for every team because you're guaranteed
to get a handful of new names that we
simply haven't
to talk about alright the other second
round pick for me I'm going back to the
offensive line here I know they invested
a lot of resources into this unit last
year keep stacking the deck I went with
Trey Smith because I think he could play
right tackle I think he could play guard
he's been phenomenal at guard for
Tennessee say it all the time round one
Talent you know probably day three
medical situation probably puts them
somewhere in the middle there and around
two for Trey Smith to really really get
this ground game cooking again for
Atlanta yeah Trey Smith is weird because
they're our first round tape there's and
there's first-round traits obviously he
was a five-star prospect coming out of
high school
the injuries are just massive you just I
have no idea what to expect with this so
we have to wait and see on that rad
three pick 70 mentioned it earlier Devon
to Freeman could be gone from this team
I think there's a strong chance to that
they don't really have anyone behind him
where you feel great about them being
the guy so this might even be a little
late for running back but Keyshawn
Vaughn and I think it was last week you
talked about him Connor this was a
player I I have him as the top senior
running back in the country and had him
at asked such over the summer we have
forgotten about him because Vanderbilt
has been so bad this year so the fact
that Keyshawn Vaughn is still producing
on a bad vanderbilt offense you know
wants the quarterback went down there
everything just fell apart
I think we see him in Mobile and I think
he regained some of his stock because he
is electric as a runner what he does is
a receiver out of the backfield is
really nice as well so this might be
again this might be too late to address
the running back position but if it's
Mike McDaniel this is probably too early
to address the running back okay but I
like Keyshawn vano
a lot in this offense I do too I think
he'll be the player that a lot of draft
Scouts are drooling over down in Mobile
because let's be real a lot of people
don't get to watch Vandy and Don is
absolutely a blazer in terms of speed he
can catch the ball very well and I think
that's a really good value
I picked 70 for him that's probably his
sweet spot and I think that would have
been a sweet spot last year I'm going
with corner here and this might surprise
you
I have CJ Henderson falling 270 is that
a surprise I think so a little bit but
I'ma be honest Matt we do this every
year with Florida defensive backs every
single year we go right this guy in the
first round this guy in the first round
and then they fall whether it's the
second third fourth round it happens
every single year with these Florida
defensive back
I like CJ Henderson's athleticism I
think he has a lot of tools to help in
coverage I don't think he's very
physical
I think he's not very technically sound
right now and I think teams will really
tap in and want to know the kind of
personality the kind of character CJ
Henderson has I'm not sure where that's
at right now and that's being honest I
don't know if it's great if it's bad if
it's somewhere in the middle but when i
strictly watch the player on film i
think he's more in the top 75 range than
the top 30 interesting yeah I mean he's
Florida DBS not doing great and I know I
talked about this with bucks fans
they're like please stop giving us
Florida players they're just over it I'm
done right Brian Poole pick six this
weekend it might be the best one
directed fourth-round pick 101 if they
can't keep Austin Hooper this could be
an earlier need for them but I think
they find a way to make that happen
Adam Trotman from Dayton a big tight end
prospect would be a nice solution here
with or without Hooper because another
guy that's just going to be able to beat
teams over the top six foot six 253
pounds and we saw the Falcons double
down on this when it was Hooper and toy
Lolo it's like we're just gonna get tall
tight ends and throw the ball up if
they're still going with that type of
prototype a tight end I think Troutman
is somebody that definitely fits this
and another guy who I think he is going
to see a nice stock rise I have him at
106 overall right now I think we could
see him get a little boost from the
Senior Bowl yes we sit on the Monday
show live from Stanford I think this
tight end class is gonna be a late
bloomer kind of group I think a lot of
guys are just sitting back and then when
we dive into the all 22 a lot of them
will make a jump which that happens in
that position every year because you get
to see them block you get to see some of
these guys from smaller programs that
we're simply not watching while we're on
the tailgate tour every single week all
right round four you went running back
round three I'll piggyback off you're
here in round four I'm going with Zack
Moss now assuming my prediction comes
wrong that Georgia does not win the SEC
Championship which is very likely
especially with the way the offense
looks right now I want to see Utah in
the playoff and the dude that carries
this Utah offense is Zach Moss
he is strictly he's a classic not gonna
get your aft until round three four or
five maybe even six he's a bruiser
he is a workhorse he carries the ball it
seems like at least 20 times a game he's
gone over a hundred yards his last four
he went over 200 yards against Arizona
Utah's winning in dominating fashion
right now where if you're looking for
that four team and Georgia can't win the
SEC Championship I would love to see
Utah in it and I really want to see more
Zach Moss I think he'd be a great fit
here on day three to kicked a three off
here for the Falcons I love that pick
for them I love Zach Moss like Moss and
Vaughn at the Senior Bowl are gonna make
the running back drills so much fun to
watch just because they're very
different but lightning and thunder my
goodness it's gonna be a blast round
five I'm going to the linebacker
position you address this early on and
the Falcons have good athletes of this
position I love Deion Jones was a huge
fan of his coming out of college but I
think they need they need more here is
where I find this team at and round five
not always gonna get a high caliber
contributor but Joe Bochy someone we've
talked about a decent amount on this
show probably would have gone earlier
but suspended for peds that's gonna
knock him down the board a little bit I
think this is just a smart value pick at
a position even if not of pressing need
it is definitely a future need for the
Falcons yeah I really like Bochy I know
he's gonna fall because of the
suspension which is really disappointing
but when you look at him he might be one
of those day three linebackers we've
seen a lot of them hang around play good
special teams and fill in when their
name is called round five for me I'm
double dipping here on pass rusher got
Curtis Weaver at the top around two now
go Bradley and I was thinking with Utah
here bring Utah over to Atlanta and I
would 11 sacks this year that spin move
he had this week against Arizona oh my
goodness and he's another guy that's
gonna be at the Senior Bowl do I think
he's the perfect player no but do I
think he's an underrated pass rusher in
this class
I certainly do I really like what he
brings to the table and for Atlanta you
got to just stack the deck would pass
rushers this is the kind of guy you take
the swinging gamble on in round five so
I have an eye a little bit higher than
this and I'll say the only reason that I
that I'm not like banging the table
right
now I've been like no no he's gonna go
so much earlier I don't know how tall he
is and that might sound like a really
weird thing to like complain about but
he could slip because I don't know how
tall and long he will be and in a group
with a lot of like big prototypical pass
rushers I think he's a really
interesting name that I'm glad he's
gonna be at the Senior Bowl because you
know guys like we haven't seen Kenny
Willa kiss it commit to the Senior Bowl
yet and that might be on Michigan State
but I think Bradley and I Jabari Zuniga
those two pass rushers especially guys
who are a little bit shorter have a big
chance to move up this year just because
you know we're not gonna see chase young
there we're not gonna see gross meadows
they're like so these edge players and
the two alabama guys who are hopefully
finally healthy have a chance to really
improve their stock sixth-round i might
surprise some people here but the
Atlanta Falcons badly need a backup
quarterback you cannot have Matt Schaub
as your backup quarterback in 2019 I'm
sorry and Matt Ryan shouldn't in 2015
right Matt Ryan's fantastic but he's
also getting older and I think you have
to have a plan for the future here not
to say round six is a plan for the
future but it's time to start throwing
some late picks at backup quarterbacks
I'm going with Nate Stanley here and no
I don't think Nate Stanley's the
quarterback of the future but I think he
has shown at times enough traits for me
to believe that he could be a really
good backup quarterback and some of that
if if Matt Ryan has an ankle injury he
can come in for a game or two and hold
down the fort I mean it's been the year
the back up across the NFL right now it
seems like everybody seemed to find one
except the the New York Jets and Chicago
Bears so when it comes down to it listen
take the swing for the fences at the end
of day three on some of these guys you
might have the next Gardner Minshew you
might have the next Kyle Allen I went
with wide receiver here just kind of get
another body in that group collage of
Lipscomb I think he's had what I would
consider kind of a disappointing year
but I still think he's a good player
really liked him over the summer and you
kind of said it earlier with Keyshawn
Vaughn Matt if you're a player on
Vanderbilt you probably want to burn
this tape this year it's been a tough
year for them they've had some awful
awful games have gotten blown out by
Florida they got blown out by a Kentucky
team that had to move wide receiver Lynn
Bowden
it's a quarterback so it's not been good
over there but Lipscomb is still a guy
that could
way and I think in the six round you
know you have Julio under contract you
have Calvin Ridley but you still always
need guys's depth insurance and I think
Lipscomb is exactly that at the next
level all right let's take a break we
come back we're gonna get into a loaded
two segments of draft on draft all right
it is draft on draft time we got two
loaded segments two questions for you
guys because you've just been
overflowing our Twitter inboxes with
questions let's jump into a Connor
Thomas Burton says as a sad Bears fan
what if we were to use our top two three
or four picks hold on quarterbacks not
trade those but just draft one every
pick I I am fascinated by this strategy
I think that you would be kicked out of
the NFL now you would be run out of the
gym if you did this one please send more
questions like this cuz I love this [ __ ]
here's the problem you wouldn't be able
to give them reps that's right you can't
I love the idea now should they pick two
maybe I could sit there and argue that
they should be especially if they took a
guy like Jordan Love and then likes
someone I don't know like you don't I
mean like Jordan loves so raw yep that
you're like oh maybe he just hits early
with more help well and like the hackers
did this back in the day it was right if
they're taking our Rodgers they took
Brian Brom and Matt Flynn right and
Brian Brom obviously flamed out but they
were able to develop matt flynn and and
you know get decent value for him so I I
do love the idea but the Bears just
don't have a lot of draft picks and
actually have so many needs like you're
not a quarterback away Bears fans I'm
sorry your offensive lines bad you need
another corner you're gonna need a pass
rusher when Leonard Floyd leaves so I
again I love the idea but I don't think
it's practical
that's not boredom if the Panthers were
to draft a quarterback in round one who
are the best fits out of the top seven
guys and who are the best realistic ones
could they be a good landing spot for a
developmental quarterback I think the
problem with the Panthers right now is
where you guys would be draft
thing right now you're at 16 overall so
what quarterback are you getting there
because Joe burrows gone too is gone
Justin Herbert's gone so you can fall
into this situation do you want to reach
for Jacob Eason who I don't know that
he's that different than what you have
in Kyle Allen do you want to reach for
Jordan Love who does give you some
traits but it's just it's a messy place
to draft a quarterback because you're
you're reaching for someone and I think
the Panthers are a team that right now
you have to think maybe there could be a
coaching change new owner is there Ron
Rivera seems to be you know they're
hovering around seven to nine eight and
eight every year there's gonna be a
change at quarterback this might be the
time to make a change a head coach maybe
even a general manager so I would be
surprised if they draft a quarterback
just because 16 such a bad spot to be in
for one yeah I think so too I think you
have to quit and you kind of nailed it
matt is what you're getting at 16
exponentially better than Kyle Allen I
think that's the question right there
and there's games where I like Eason
there's games where I don't think he's
even close it is so up in the air with
him and like you said even if you like
Herbert I don't think Herbert's gonna be
there I there's times for Jordan love
where I'm like wow that's a top-10 pick
there's also that that 95 other times
out of 100 where I'm like he can not be
on an NFL field next year so it's like I
don't I to answer the question those are
the best guys and the realistic options
but and you are in a position to develop
a quarterback because Kyle Allen's there
but if I'm the Panthers I'm just not
gonna panic and do that right now I'm
gonna get another piece and look at the
2021 class if it comes down to that
that's where I'm at - I would rather see
Kyle Allen with a full offseason with
number one reps and with an offense
designed for him than bet on Jacobs
Center Jordan love that's just this
where I'm at Patrick Chamberlain good
question here give us a percent
confidence these coaches should have in
their job security so he's got some
college some pro Brian Kelly I think
Brian Kelly has 95 percent job security
me too and les Urban Meyer back channels
it and says I want that job which could
happen I think Brian Kelly safe I'm with
you - I don't think Brian Kelly's going
anywhere
not my favorite coach but he's also not
a bad coach right here's the problem
with Notre Dame Notre Dame every year
they're never embarrassing Notre Dame
right away they're bad they're kind of
good exactly
Notre Dame is always in contention for
the playoff they'll always have that
disappointing loss they're they're not
in the big boys lounge they're not
sitting there with Alabama LSU now
Clemson Ohio State now a Notre Dame
views themselves as someone who should
be sitting in the big boys lounge you
have to ask yourself can we go get the
guy that could do that or do we stick
with the guy that'll have us in the top
15 every year like I don't think they'll
do the former I think they'll just roll
with Brian Kelly I think so too
here this looks close to home Tom Herman
Tom is safe none of his assistants are I
think we could see a major staff
shake-up so I think a hundred percent
confidence they know that tom is
building something there we were just
there week one all the money they're
throwing in the facilities there they
are not they're not gonna fire Tom
Herman it would take a scandal at this
point I think for him to get fired
because even though this has been a down
year the the word at Texas has always
been 20/20 like that's the class that
they that's the year they've been
building toward Sam Al Gore senior year
so they're young this year the defense
is really yeah
and I'm not defending Tom Herman at all
because it has been a disappointing year
the defense is young and it's been
banged up so I if they don't win next
year then he's on the hot seat clay
Helton I think is gone I think clay
Hilton's fired I know the fire in four
years I know us he's ranked now which i
think is just gamesmanship by the
committee to try to give like to try to
give oregon like a quality win I don't I
don't think clay Helton comes back next
year so I would say his percent
confidence and job security should be
like three percent yeah I'll go five or
ten I don't see how he survives it'd be
really weird and then this is a really
good question it's a good list what do
you think a Pat Fitzgerald I would
max - oh yeah Pat Fitzgerald and Scott
frost two guys who are coaching at their
alma mater Scott frost she's got a
two-year extension yeah you're both out
a hundred percent they're not going
anywhere
and I think the thing is you have to
realize with Northwestern is like their
Northwestern you know what I mean like
not nothing's wrong with that their
early kind of it's Cheryl gets the most
out of North West they were in the Big
Ten championship game last year they're
okay with that that will give him five
years you know of cushion say we were in
the Big Ten championship game at 2018
guys like come on settle down okay on
the pro side we'll rip through these
Jason Garrett I feel like he's at like
20 percent jobs it's over maybe it when
Jerry's finally pissed and talking [ __ ]
in the media things are bad and and it's
funny because the next guy on this list
Pat Shermer Jason Garrett has been
linked to that job if he gets fired so
Pat Shermer could be fired because Jason
Garrett is fired Matt Patricia I think
it's time to admit it's not working he's
good defensive coordinator he's not a
good head coach Mike Tomlin has 100% job
security 100 they lost Ben
Roethlisberger and would be a wild-card
team right now he's not going anywhere I
know that Tomlin doesn't have like
people don't think of him as one of the
best coaches the NFL Peter King listed
him as a potential coach of the year
Diana did I agree I agree they're six
and five and they've had to play Mason
Rudolph most of the time right
he sucks frat boy quarterback yeah I
mean it's amazing what Mike Tomlin has
gotten out of this team now you know
obviously Kyle Shanahan it's probably
the coach of the year John Harbaugh you
should be coach you know you look at
those guys but man I think coach of the
year there should be like here we go
making new Awards again we're very
curious for doing this there should be
the coach of the year that's like coach
of the best team then there should be
and they'll never make this but like the
coach that made chicken salad out of
chicken [ __ ] like the most improved
I don't yeah something like that would
be like I mean even what the Colts are 6
& 5 right referring to so man that's
know my Tom one hit but the rest man I
think all three of those guys are gone
the Lions are a goddamn mess what
happens her since we said that they had
such a good start trading queue might be
like the nail in the coffin which sounds
like a weird thing to trade like a late
round pick who plays safety but he's
been so good in Seattle and it's obvious
every week that they didn't handle that
right all right let's take a break we
come back for more draft draft questions
and we're gonna get you guys off to your
Thanksgiving dinner back on draft on
draft kool Terry asked what are your
thoughts on AJ Dillon have seen a wide
variety of opinions on him also he has
two questions if the Cowboys can't land
landen Riley who be their next best
option to replace Jason Garrett let's
start with AJ Dillon
I like AJ Dillon I like him a lot as a
college running back I have a day three
grade on him like around 4 so early day
3 great on him he's just I mean he's
such a wrecking ball and I think we can
look at so the way I do this was
scouting is and this is kind of similar
to Derek Henry how many guys like AJ
Dillon are having success in the NFL and
the answer is really one and I think
Derek Henry's just I mean different
physically from AJ Dillon so when it's
when you look at scouting that way
you're gonna miss on guys you know
you're gonna miss on Lamar Jackson
you're gonna miss on you know guys who
just are outside the mold and that's
gonna happen yeah and I think it's okay
95% of time you're gonna be right
because these guys don't fit the mold
and 5% of time you're gonna be really
wrong because the guys who have success
outside the mold they break the [ __ ]
mold and I think that's what we've seen
with Lamar so with AJ Dillon it's like
okay he's not as fast as Derek Henry and
Derek Henry is just somehow an untaek
Lobel force they even when he's not
moving fast people cannot tackle him I
don't get that vibe from AJ Dillon so
that's why I don't think of him as you
know round 2 player like it like Derek
Henry was yeah I'm with you there and I
think the problem is - a lot of people
would be like well can you use him how
Kyle Shanahan uses fullbacks get him
involved in all these exotic passing
schemes and stuff um block because he is
250 pounds which is a gigantic running
back but he's not that kind of pass
catcher yet either
you know he's caught 11 balls this year
for almost 200 yards which is great but
he's not the kind of guy that yet
think is a mismatch in that regard so
I'm with you there he is worthy of
drought draft pick and he can handle the
rock of million times a game but the
question is how effective he is that
really remains to be seen at that level
where a lot of guys in his play style
are not yep and as to your second
question who could replace Jason Garrett
we're gonna be fixing the Cowboys very
soon had the way things are going so
hold on to your hats and we'll have time
to research that and give you more of a
well rounded answer at bow Jets one
what round will Bryce Hall get drafted
in the Virginia corner
Bryce Hall I know that before the year
this guy had a lot of love from folks on
Twitter but he broke his tibia and fibia
in mid-october and those like that's big
so he's gonna miss the Senior Bowl
obviously he's most likely gonna miss
the combine I have a round 2/3 great on
him but it's with like a red line
through it because so that means it
depends on medical where he's at because
yeah that type of injury I that's it's
not you know it's not an ACL so we're
not all familiar with it but that's
pretty devastating so it just depends on
where he's gonna be but six 100 pounds I
mean obviously he fits the eye test I
never thought that he was great as an
athlete so I was a little bit down on
him to begin with before the injury yeah
I think so too I think he'll be somebody
that in a good corner class to Matt
that's another problem here he's
probably gonna go the top of day three
when you factor in all the medical
things I mean he certainly was talented
enough to be a day to pick there's no
doubt about that but I think when it
comes down to it the injury is really
gonna hurt him and the fact that a lot
of teams I mean we're gonna have Jeff
Okuda go in the first round we're gonna
have Christian Fulton go in the first
round CJ Henderson who we talked about
on the show is gonna go in the top three
rounds most likely Jeff gladden he's
gonna go pry in the top 50 and that's
just a couple guys I mean this is a very
very good corner class but I saw was a
good player but we're gonna have to
wonder how much the injury affects him
and it could affect him by a couple
rounds
yeah and I I did like him he was a guy I
thought I talked to some people over
summer it was pegging him as like a fit
for teams like the Niner Seahawks
Jaguars is not a first-round pick but as
a good scheme fit
at krumitz what can you recommend is
affixed for the Packers let's say Oh
line wide reciever middle linebacker in
the first three rounds based on what the
GM likes to do by addressing multiple
position one position with multiple
picks what wide receivers can be picked
in a second and third round I think the
water is I threw this question here
because I love how much fans study their
GM's they like figure out their
preferences and this is a good year to
do this they do need a lot of help at
wide receiver they need help but tight
int this is a good year to do it so I
think even if we don't see the Packers
go you know back to back wide receivers
we can see them go wide receiver then
tied in and wide receiver I think you
can look at guys like Justin Jefferson
Donovan people's Jones as round two
players assuming they both come out
early this year it would be a good fit
Sage's Surratt from Wake Forest hurt
with a shoulder injury but if he comes
out as a richer sophomore I think he's
an interesting fit in round two and then
in round three you can come back around
with a hunter Bryant type a tight in
from Washington or Jared Pinkney from
Vanderbilt so this is a good year to
stack pass catchers just because of how
much talent there is in and also I think
you can come back around in like six or
seven and look at trait type receivers
you know guys who aren't gonna be you
know they're not gonna be the fastest
and best route runners but you might be
able to just find you know a guy like KJ
Hill at Ohio State who hasn't had a
great year per terms of production but
was really good with Dewayne Haskins the
quarterback and has speed so you could
get someone a little bit later that
couldn't fill in a bit of the gaps
yeah Jennings from Tennessee is another
one of those guys no speed but you take
him on day three and yeah he's super
physical guy physical in his routes
monster after the catch
I think another guy that would be
interesting for Green Bay on Tates
Hewitt wide receiver is KJ hammer you
see what the Ravens have done they've
built this ground attack that could
stretch the field vertically you see the
Packers Aaron Jones is the focal point
of their offense but if they can get a
wide receiver that could also threaten
the field vertically Hamlin's probably
that guy on day two he's small very very
fast and something we're gonna talk
about with this team and I really like
that krumitz mentioned it in the
question here they're gonna have to add
some pieces to the offensive line they
got a great one Nelligan Jenkins last
year but they got to keep stacking the
deck with offensive lineman as those
tackles get a little bit older yep last
question from Garrett Greenlee at what
point does age
my concern with draft prospects so
boilerplate answer the way that I was
taught to evaluate if a player turns 24
in their rookie season you note it and
you try to evaluate with that context I
think that we at times because scouting
is hard you like look for anything to
put a player over another so it's like
we're time I would say I'm Donald a 20
loaves a twenty-year-old basically draft
pick versus a jobber Oh who's gonna be
23 what is row is six months older than
Sam right so like what are the what are
the benefits there with Sam Donald it's
like okay he's only 22 but does that
mean that he can be developed more than
burro who's currently 22 so I think
that's I don't know the answer to it
it's definitely something we pay
attention to but as a rule of thumb 24
year old rookie is something that you
might red flag so I've actually heard
both sides of this argument I've heard
the Sam d'Arnaud Lamar Jackson draft
young guys because they have more
development potential I've also heard it
the other way where guys say I would
rather especially a quarterback have the
more mature physical like the guy's
body's already matured physically we
know what he is where he's going and
quarterbacks are playing until their
late 30s now so does that make as much
of a difference like you're gonna get
your 15 years of hits in the NFL
basically whether you start those hits
21 or at 23 24 so it's it's not as much
a concern at quarterback as it might be
for running backs where there's a 30
year it seems like shut you know that's
your limit wide receiver really there's
not look at how many receivers perform
after 30 it's like Larry Fitzgerald
that's it so I think for skilled players
that matters a lot more than
quarterbacks yeah I think so too
I think Corner it also really sets
ceiling I mean a lot of times when a
player is you know a 24 year old
prospect 23 year old prospect you kind
of know what they are a little more so
you're not gonna sit there and say well
this guy will get this drastically
better
we're like the perfect example Matt
remember Tremayne Edmonds was 19 yeah
it's a prospect and you watched her made
out of ins play and you go okay these
there's a lot of mistakes that he makes
but the flash plays at 19 years old and
under good coaching which he's had in
Buffalo and has helped him develop that
sets a ceiling that is other
worldly compared to a linebacker that
would be 23 years old that said four
years yeah four more years of play in
front of him and I think it's something
that's interesting what a lot of
prospects this year I know a lot of Jets
fans are frustrated with Quinn and
Williams Quintin Williams was another
young guy a one-year starter at Alabama
he needs to get stronger he doesn't to
get I mean he's on the ground a lot he
has not been very good and does that
mean we're out on Quinn and Williams no
a lot of people compared him including
myself to Fletcher Cox Fletcher Coxon
have a great rookie season they turned
in one of the best offensive linemen
we've seen the last decade so that's a
really couple different examples you
also have around him yeah sure so and
you know it depends what the scheme asks
you to do but just going back to
prospect age yeah I do think it factors
in greatly it's very important but it's
also very important how to value it
because I see people on Twitter go oh
this guy's 24 I don't want them yes one
of these a good player it's not that
easy it's not everything and I would say
this about 40 times three cone times
advanced statistics age everything is
just part of the puzzle like I don't
know that one piece should be bigger
than the other in terms of just
generally speaking they're all very
important pieces besides the bench press
yeah right so important the bench press
numbers if I could I actually told some
of the CEO day if I could only take one
test to evaluate a prospect if they took
everything away and you like you get one
thing it would be three Conan I would be
three cone Finch president worthless
absolutely three cones more valuable
than the 40 most of the time without a
doubt without it unless your DK Metcalf
apparently you're an anomaly so that is
our show
happy Thanksgiving meet all of you enjoy
your your time with your family have
saved travels again the Friday show will
be a best-of with four of our favorite
interviews in the last year and then we
will be back as normal Monday kicking
off December getting into draft season
for all these teams I'm sure we will
have a mock draft Monday for you guys so
for Connor and Melo Happy Thanksgiving
we'll talk to y'all real soon